[Music]
this week on booknotes our guest is
robert putnam professor of public policy
at harvard university he joins us to
discuss his recent book bowling alone
the collapse and revival of american
community
[Music]
robert d putnam author of bowling alone
what's the theory of your book
well my theory is that connecting
with other people
has great value
for us personally and for our
communities
i use the term social capital in the
book
to refer to the fact that social
networks have
value they have value for the people who
are
in them
most people in america for example get
their jobs through him they know i did i
did and most people do i don't mean that
in a nepotistic sense i just mean we
learn about jobs through through social
connections
and there are many other
values to us personally
from our social connections there are
positive effects on health from
connecting with other people
but social connections also have value
for
people who are not directly in the
networks
if you live in a neighborhood where
people know one another for example as i
do that holds down the crime rate
in the neighborhood even for people who
don't themselves
go to the barbecues in the neighborhood
that is
the general effects of social capital of
social connections spread across the
community they lower crime rates they
improve performance in schools
they have many positive effects and so
the theory of the book is that
social capital social connections
community connections have value for
people
america has historically
been blessed with very high levels of
social capital compared to most other
countries we do connect with one another
and that's
been an important part of our
advantage historically as a country
and for most of the last
century or so
that was more and more true of americans
we were year by year connecting more
with one another we were
going to meetings more belonging to the
pta belonging to civic groups having
friends over to the house giving more
our generosity
was rising year by year in terms of the
fraction of our income that we gave to
other people
and then somehow mysteriously
about uh
oh
25 or 30 years ago
all those trends
turned downward and began doing all
those things less connecting less with
other people and so this book is about
uh first of all the fact demonstrating
that that's a quite pervasive trend
across american society and then trying
to explore
why it happened and and what difference
it makes and what we might do about it
bowling alone where'd you get the title
well i was doing some work on the
question of membership in various
organizations the fact that people were
no longer blowing into the you know elks
club or the rotary club or the league
women voters and i happened to run into
a friend who owned a bowling alley
and he said gosh bob you don't know it
but you've stumbled onto the major
economic
problems facing my industry because
although more americans are bowling than
ever before bowling is up in america
bowling in leagues
bowling in teams
is off by about 60 percent
and the money it turns out in bowling is
in the beer and pretzels because when
you buy when you drink when you when you
a bowl in a league you drink four times
as much beer and you
eat four times as many pretzels and the
money in bowling is in the beer and
pretzels not in the balls and shoes so
they were in this funny situation in
which he was aware of the fact that
people were bowling more but not bowling
in leagues and uh
so i thought that captured the fact that
we were we were not connecting with our
friends and neighbors as much as we as
we once did and i wanted to get across
the idea that it wasn't just in
kind of do-gooding ways that we were not
connecting it wasn't just that we were
no longer voting although voting is down
as everybody knows it wasn't just that
we were you know no longer belonging to
some kind of organization that does good
but it was also that we were not even
connecting in informal
ways with our friends and neighbors
that's why i used the title there was a
time where you panicked
because you had a data problem yeah
well as in writing this book as as in
writing other books that i've done um
i
uh followed a plan of writing an article
in which you sort of lay out where you
think you're going and trying to listen
to what people have to say about it um
usually in the past since i'm an
academic most of the books that i've
written i got responses from two or
three people in response to that initial
article this time the the article
bowling alone happened to get a lot more
attention and so i got
letters and comments and so on from
thousands of people and what year was
that 1995 1995 magazine a little journal
called the journal of democracy which
had i think a total paid circulation of
about five people it was really very
obscure
but the
but the journal but the article happened
to catch people's attention i don't know
quite why i have some suspicions about
that but anyway it it caught a lot of
attention and got a lot of positive
attention and and a lot of people said
gee but wait a minute if you just took a
broader
uh maybe things wouldn't look so bleak
maybe maybe the things you looked at are
declining but other things are not
declining
and so i spent some time trying to
figure out whether that was true whether
they're actually whether maybe i
overstated the case in that initial
article and
early in that process i discovered that
one of the data sets that i had been
using
had a flaw a technical flaw in it not
actually one that i had
put in it but it meant that there had
been an undercounting of group
memberships and so
all when you made a correction for that
although the trends were still down they
weren't down nearly as much and so
that was a point which i thought
well maybe i really did get carried away
with this original uh argument and maybe
the trends really aren't down as much as
i thought
so how was that how did you correct it
well we were easy to correct that
particular data but the main the larger
uh just by by you know doing the doing
the numbers in the in the proper way
they had forgotten to count pta
memberships or something in their in
their total account
what the more important thing that
happened was that um
we discovered uh after the original
article i remember was was intended to
be a kind of preliminary thing we
discovered two massive
new archives of survey evidence whose
existence i hadn't even known of before
indeed nobody had known these two
massive archives
based on surveys with
large numbers of americans every month
in one case every year in the other case
since 1975 year after year asking people
about how often they went to meetings
and how often they
went to club meetings and how often they
volunteered and how often they had
friends over to the house and went on
picnics and so on
and until that point we had no idea that
anybody been gathering data on picnics
who knew whether picnics were up or down
but but uh once we had this
really amazingly rich evidence it
provides a deep kind of
like a moving picture
of how american social habits have
changed over the course of the of the
last quarter century
and i was shocked when i discovered that
evidence because what it turned out was
when you took into account people had
said you know if you take into account a
broader range of things it'll turn out
things are not so bleak and i took into
account a broader range of things and
just not turned out things were even
bleaker
then i thought it was not just that we
were stopping going to meetings we still
claimed to be members of groups but we
stopped going to meetings so we were we
were not showing up we were not and we
weren't going to uh we weren't involved
in other sorts of community activities
we weren't signing petitions as much as
we used to
but also we weren't uh having friends
over the house we weren't going on
picnics we weren't having dinner parties
we weren't going to the bar going to
bars or down by about 35 or 40 percent
uh we were not even having dinner with
our own families
this fuller evidence suggested so
it turned out uh once we had the full
range of evidence and that's what's
reported in this book that
the original article um
was mistaken only in that it understated
the full range and depth and tread and
and breadth of these these kinds of
declines in our connectedness
where is your neighborhood
i live well actually i'm fortunate we
live in two places i live in lexington
massachusetts i teach at harvard and i
live in lexington massachusetts a suburb
of boston
it's a it's a nice little neighborhood
where people do actually uh have
barbecues and so on
and then we have a a little house up in
new hampshire where i go and i want to
write and so i we have friends and local
connections there too so
what's the difference between frostbound
new hampshire and lexington
well that's a very very good question uh
brian um in in the boston metropolitan
area there are
generally speaking people are less
connected with one another with their
neighbors than they are in a small town
that's true and specifically of
of jaffrey new hampshire where frost
pond is uh located people in
in jeffrey uh all the time know each
other if i go into you know the grocery
store to get potato salad they know what
kind of potato salad i want if i if i go
into the grocery store and um in
lexington you know i don't want to ever
remember who i am
um so there are big differences in the
level of social connection people are
more likely to vote in in the small town
in new hampshire than they are in the
in uh in the boston area they're they're
more likely to volunteer they're more
likely to shovel one another's
you know rocks or whatever
so there are differences that mirror in
fact differences um
nationwide between smaller places and
and bigger urban areas
but the striking thing is if you compare
uh jaffrey new hampshire 2000
well if you compare jeffrey new
hampshire in the year 2000 with boston
in the year 2000 jeffrey has a lot more
social connections
but if you compare geoffrey new
hampshire 2000 with jeffrey 1960
which i can do what you can do by just
talking old-timers or looking at the
newspapers or whatever there's been a
big decline there too in other words
what i'm trying to say is these these
trends downward in
social connections whether we're talking
about clubs or just having friends over
are true everywhere across america this
is really an equal opportunity
affliction that's that struck our
society
harvard you teach what does public
policy at the kennedy school of
government how long have you done that
i've been there about 20 years before
that i was the university of michigan
for a little more than 10 years and
and there too i've taught international
relations and and now american politics
where did you grow up i grew up in a
little town in ohio a little town called
port clinton ohio population then and
now 5 000. what was the family like
uh my family
my dad was a
building contractor my mom was a
schoolteacher uh we'd come there after
the war
my dad had been uh injured during the
war and uh he was recovering
and
i had a younger sister still do and
it was a it was
a pleasant place to grow up in a
pleasant time to grow up in i mean i it
was a much less you know cosmopolitan
place than
harvard
or or the east coast in general um
but uh i was really blessed in growing
up in a place that had a lot of social
capital and frankly i've
i've spent some time worrying and
writing this book about the degree to
which what i'm
indulging in here is simple nostalgia
for a kind of a of a of a past that one
wouldn't necessarily today want to
recreate
um
i haven't been back to portland for a
long time until i until just recently i
went back there and it turns out it
still is in fact unusually civic people
do do connect with one another you do
mention
that in spite of the fact that you find
that
people are bowling alone in your own
environment you got a tremendous amount
of support for this book yeah sure did
and your own daughter has worked with
you for 10 years yeah
tell us about laura and what role she
played in this well it's interesting you
asked that question
lara is a
professional woman she's just gotten her
phd at the university of michigan in
latin american history she's married to
a costa rican and now lives in costa
rica and she's got three kids i'm
extremely proud of her because she's you
know one of these kind of super moms
who's raising a family and taking care
of her mother-in-law there in costa rica
and also
writing
and we are very close uh personally have
been for a long time she's been the
person who's been my most severe critic
because we know each other well enough
that she feels free to say things that
people might not say about gee that's a
dumb way of phrasing that idea or
or i think it'll toss out that chapter
entirely
um
and we at the time i was writing this
book she was also doing her dissertation
and we both happen to be night people we
work right late at night
uh so
lots of the time we we'd spend uh in the
middle of the night me at frost pond and
she and
in costa rica and exchanging emails
about
how we were making how well we were
making out that evening did she feel the
same way you do about the
bowling alone concept yeah she does
actually um
absolutely she's been very helpful
very helpful in fact in getting me to
see the trend as well through the eyes
of someone of a different generation
because there are such
big generational differences
in the degree to which americans
are connected with their communities and
in the ways that they connect
with their communities
there's a risk that someone in you know
late middle age my age
may just be
blind to new forms of social connection
that were that are emerging among
younger folks and uh i don't want to
hold her responsible for any remaining
blind spots but we did talk a lot
actually as i was writing it about well
how would this problem look if it were
if the book were but being written by a
20 something or a 30 something rather
than a 50 something
you spend a lot of time on
not a lot of time you spend a chapter on
television and media uh and the water
cooler
effect what's that
well the watercolor people say that if
you know we all watch survivor we can
get together around the water cooler and
that's that's almost as good connections
as as if we uh you know we're connecting
over the back fence
um
but i don't find any evidence that
that's true actually um i think that
enter entertainment television
especially commercial entertainment
television
is really lethal
for civic connection i always have to
phrase the point carefully when i'm
talking about television to say
commercial entertainment television
because i know
from the statistics the watchers of
c-span and and
and some of the other news programs are
among the most civic people in america
they're also on average older than the
rest of americans and they're that's
their they represent really civic
america but unfortunately that's not the
most people in america don't watch those
sorts of programs most of them watch uh
you know survivor or friends or
or um anyone of a number of other um
television shows and those watching
those shows is very negatively
correlated
with all forms of social connection not
just the
you know going to meetings but even just
spending time with your family there's
one statistic i may not be perfectly
accurate on this but the
sixth graders
with television sets in their bedroom
went from something like six percent in
1977 up to 70 in 19 correct 97 or
whatever yep
what does that say well i i what it says
is absolutely that we're watching
television now especially our kids are
watching more television alone um i
actually had not
any idea that that trend had occurred
because my kids were a little older than
that and so we that that happened after
we had
uh young kids and uh and i don't know
that we would have been immune to it if
our kids had been that young i don't
want to claim
uh status here as a somehow a saint with
respect to television watching but what
what the trend means
is that more and more of the time of our
kids is spent alone
watching television without anybody else
present or certainly without any adult
present
uh
i i think that that study that that that
i cite in the book comes from the kaiser
family foundation study which also
i think shows that uh 95 of the time
that kids are watching television
they're not their parents are not
present
um
and
um that kind and by the way it's just
not it's not just kids it's adults too
who are mostly watching
uh television alone
um but with respect to our kids that
can't be a good that can't be good
actually
um
and there's another
uh interesting finding uh recently
actually
um just this spring the ymca released a
survey in which they had asked kids
adolescence would you
like to spend more time with your
parents or the same amount of time you
do spend with your parents or less time
with your parents adolescence remember
these are kids brian who don't you know
adolescents in general are not
wanting to spend a lot of time hanging
out with with mom and dad but in fact
two-thirds of american adolescents say
they'd like to spend more time with
their parents
and what that says to me is that
for a variety of reasons
we've disengaged from our kids we're
using television as increasingly
a kind of cheap daycare
and
and that's
i'm afraid laying the groundwork for yet
more civic disengagement down the road
how much did vietnam and or watergate
have to do with this change over the
last 25 years it's a good question it's
not an easy question to answer because
um
it certainly is clear that the
generation
of people who who were exposed to that
uh and only to that that is who came of
age
during the midst of vietnam and
watergate and so on
are less civically engaged
and i can believe
that
people say have stopped voting because
they are upset about
you know watergate or vietnam or moniker
or whatever
but remember the picture that's being
described here is much broader than that
it's not just that we're dropping out of
politics we're dropping out of
connections of all sort and it's harder
for me to believe that people have
stopped going on picnics
because they're upset about monica or
they're they've stopped
you know having friends over to the
house because they're still mad at dick
nixon i did that that kind of connection
doesn't seem to me very plausible and
that's why i think that
probably in the
big
patterns of social disconnection that
i'm talking about here these purely
political causes the political
alienation that did certainly arise
uh out of it i mean watergate probably
isn't the main explanation for the
broader trend i think are we um
happier or
more unhappy than we used to be in your
opinion um well generally speaking we're
we're less a little less happy than we
used to be despite the fact that our
income has doubled or tripled over the
last 30 years we're less little less
happy how do we know that uh well
because in the several different recent
ways one is we've been
you know pollster has been asking people
about the state of their happiness uh
for well for the last 50 years actually
um there's a more and and there are
other ways too for example depression
clinically measured depression i don't
mean just feeling a little blue in the
morning or i don't mean going to the
shrink more but clinically measured
depression
has uh has increased tenfold over this
period i don't know how many of your
viewers will know that we're in the
midst of a of a depression epidemic
nationwide and as i say this is not just
that we've become more
sensitive to that problem it's that the
real symptoms have have increased a lot
um
but there's another subtlety here which
is even more telling
um
it used to be that
as you got older
you got less happy there there was a
there was a
negative correlation between age
and happiness that you young people were
happier and you know they had more their
whole life in front of them and so on
and gradually over the course of the
last 30 or 40 years that correlation
between age and happiness has reversed
be so that now young people are much
less happy
than older people and the reason is i
think
tied up what we're talking about here
the same thing is true the depression by
the way the depression epidemic has hit
distinctively
younger generations not older
generations and it's the younger
generations also who bowling alone shows
have been disengaging so
i don't want to be practicing psychiatry
here without a license but i do think
that the circumstantial evidence is that
a whole generation of people beginning
with the boomers and then increasing
with the extras have become
less connected with one another
and less connected with their
communities
and they at the same time have become
less happy
there's been a substantial increase in
depression and i have to say also a
substantial increase in in in suicide
rates in that generation where suicide
rates among the the connected generation
the old the long civic generation have
been been quite low so
i think we are less happy is the short
answer to the question go back to
something you said earlier about how
this all got started you wrote the
original article again in what magazine
the journal of democracy whose is that
uh it's uh
an academic article a academic journal
published by the national endowment for
democracy uh it's it's a journal mainly
for academics about about you know how
democracy works and you said you had a
theory about how that
moved on from there well yeah um
i've written a lot of books and a lot of
articles in my life as an academic and
some of them i think were maybe even
better than the bowling allen article
but that got about a million times more
publicity i mean i got
you know invited on uh people on people
magazine and bill clinton invited me to
camp david there was just a lot of
hubbub about about the article bullying
alone much more than as i say for things
that were i think equally valuable
intellectually and i think the reason
was that i
purely
blindly stumbled into
articulating
a trend
in our lives
that
lots of ordinary americans knew was true
in their life that they weren't you know
their mom had belonged hadassah and they
didn't or that their dad
had gone to the moose club or the rotary
club and they didn't do anything
equivalent or that they you know
remember that they used to their parents
used to play bridge every week and with
friends and have friends over the house
and they didn't everybody kind of knew
in a
personal way
that they were less connected with their
community than their parents had been
and felt a little uneasy about it
you know felt they knew probably why
because they were busy or whatever but
they they felt a little uneasy about it
and they but they it was defined
not as a public issue but as a private
issue then along comes this harvard
professor who says actually no it's not
just you it's all of us
and i think that the reason that the the
original article got so much attention
was that it seemed to put a label
to something that all of us felt in our
lives but didn't realize that everybody
else was feeling
and um that's the only reason i can
make of the fact that it got so so much
more attention than
i'd ever dreamed of when were you called
to camp david
oh essentially right after the that
article uh came out the president had a
number of of uh academics to come to
camp david to talk with him about uh
this was the this was uh
january of
1995. and uh it was shortly after the
article had appeared and he was thinking
about
um
what he uh
what he would say in the state of the
union message that year and so he was
talking with me and some other people
about what did you learn from that
experience
well i
i learned of course it was a treat to be
to be invited and uh and i very much
enjoyed meeting the president and and um
and the vice president and
they're smart people there i learned
that they they do just fine in a harvard
seminar
and
i also learned that it's complicated to
think about that the movement from
describing these issues in a purely
academic way which is frankly what i had
done before i was
entirely been an academic
is different from the problem of
figuring out what would you do to fix it
um and what i was increasingly
confronted with not i don't just mean it
to cam david but that was an example of
it
as there came to be more discussion
about the so-called bowling alone
phenomenon and
was okay if you're so smart to discard
to diagnose this problem how do we fix
it and so i spent actually much of the
last five years
in what is a somewhat different task
than the pride pro than the problem of
diagnosis which is to
what could we do to change our lives or
our community or our public policies or
whatever
to enable us to re-weave the fabric
let me go back to that water cooler
thing for a moment because this network
is about 21 years old and for 20 years
we've had call-in programs where people
every day for three hours communicate
among the group that watches
you can go from this network to any
other dr laura or sure rush limbaugh or
any number of national call-in programs
which weren't there they haven't been
there but 22 years or something like
that larry king started it all in 78 on
a national basis
that's not discussed in your book and i
wonder
that's a community we all we have all
formed communities where people are
involved
albeit in many cases alone sure that
they're talking to a community what imp
what impact has that had on this you
know and is the water cooler thing
better for us as a country or worse for
us that we all watch the same thing and
talk about it the next day
um
well if we actually did talk about it
with people we we in in a face-to-face
setting in which we really know one
another uh it'd be fine i don't see
anything there's any you know
nothing
bad about talking about survivor any
more than talking about the
you know the local bond issue or
whatever else you talk about with
friends i do think that face-to-face
connections are really important that is
i don't doubt for a second that i know
this from my own experience that your
viewers
feel that they have a kind of a personal
connection with you and i think the same
thing is true for
any of the hosts of these these programs
in a certain sense they feel part of a
larger community a community of the
people who identify themselves with
you know watching larry king or watching
rush limbaugh or whatever
but
that the horizontal ties among the
members of that among the members of
those audience are much weaker than the
horizontal ties that would be true among
people over our back fence
um
and uh
i so i do actually look at i did look in
the course of doing this work at the
question of talk radio and
and talk television and um
and i do think that
uh for some people those sorts of of
being in an audience of that sort does
give them a sense of belonging to
something wider than themselves
but the other watchers are the other
people the other viewers are not going
to bring you chicken soup if you get if
you get sick that is there are certain
kinds of things that only real
face-to-face connections uh can do
being in a community of
identity that is a community that that
shares basically only the fact they
think of themselves in the same way the
community of adida adidas shoes wearers
for example people i mean now
communities the term communities used in
marketing all the time the you know the
buick community or something
um
being is very different from a community
of interaction
in which you actually do connect with
other people in it
and um
so i don't want to be dismissive of
communities of identity pure pure
identity
but i don't think it solves the same
serves the same kind of functions either
the functions for our own physical
health or the
or the social functions in our community
your you know the i don't know of any
evidence at all that uh where
people are more likely to
watch rush limbaugh their schools work
better i know of a lot of evidence
that where people are involved in
community organizations the schools work
better
so the kind of social capital that i'm
talking about i think does require more
than you merely more than you merely
being an audience it requires really
connecting
would the country be better off with a
strong active
federal government
or
strong local governments in the
environment that you think is the best
for
us as citizens
i try to avoid in the book and in my own
thinking about this any simple
dichotomy would we want a top-down
solution or a bottom-up solution because
i think we want both top-down and
bottom-up solutions
i do think that the evidence is that
smaller is better for connecting smaller
towns or smaller schools for example
because you feel a greater sense of
efficacy if you're
if you're close up to if if you can
actually you know connect with other
real people in the and that's that's an
argument i think for
for a more decentralized form of of
connection on the other hand there are
clearly examples in our history
in which a crucial role has been played
by the federal government in building
community let me give
a couple of specific examples many
people in america don't know that the
4-h club which for a certain generation
of us the 4-h club was you know the
place where you learn
learn to connect with other people
especially in rural communities the 4-h
couple is a government program run out
of
a government bureaucracy run out of the
department of agriculture
and it was created by people in the
around the in the progressive era by
people who thought that the government
was the government's responsibility to
help
people connect with other people in
their communities and
um
the
the
the whole many of the forms of social
connection in our rural areas
are uh lagrange and so on are the
creation of county agents county agents
i mean you know i always thought that
county agents were people who told my
mom how to can goods or or taught
farmers how to what kind of
what kind of uh
plants to grow but county agents were
paid community organizers paid by the
government bureaucrats
uh
the phrase i'm trying to phrase it that
way not to castigate them but to say
look deep in our own history as a
country are many examples in which the
government played an important role
in building the preconditions for
for community take another example the
gi bill after world war
ii
i think was an important factor
in giving that generation basically the
gis out of world war ii a sense of civic
involvement a sense of reciprocity the
government you know they had
given a lot to the country in in terms
of their service in war the country gave
back to them in terms of the this
opportunity that most of them had never
imagined they would have to go to go to
college and they in turn over the rest
of their lives gave back that long it
appears very clearly in the book this
long civic generation that world war ii
generation all their lives have been
more involved in the community giving
more trusting more schmoozing more
joining more and i think you can't get
around the fact that that must have been
in part because of
policies of the federal government so i
want to say both and both
small local grassroots initiatives are
important but also there are important
federal policies that i think we need to
to recognize in the past and perhaps to
push for in the future if you had to put
everybody that worked on your book on
the statistical side and all the
research in a room how many people would
be in there
over the years probably nearly 100
people i mean they didn't all work at
the same time because i was mostly using
graduate students and it happened over
over a five or six year period that i
was working with people so sometimes we
had sometimes the team got up to
oh eight or ten people and and sometimes
it was less than that but there are a
lot of them what were they doing
um part of it was gathering statistics i
mean we looked really hard to try to
find data on membership and
organizations and uh trends in uh
in
all sorts of con connect forms of you
know connection we wanted to try to find
out what were the trends in restaurant
eating and so on and turns out that was
hard to track down a lot of those
things
and partly they were
reviewing for me helping me look at the
very wide range of research of other
people's research that we were drawing
on because much of that book is really
based on
summarizing a lot of other people's
research for example to take the issue
that you talked about before talk radio
we had we had
i had one one of my uh graduate students
who spent the better part of a semester
looking at all the research that's been
done on talk radio who watches who talks
who calls in has it changed over time
are people who call in to talk radio
more likely to be involved in their
community
uh apart from talk radio or are they
less likely to be involved so and doing
the same thing in you know dozens of
other areas we wanted
we wanted to look in some detail for
example at the
medical literature on the health effects
of social social connections and we
looked to spend a lot of time looking at
history
so i had researchers who went back and
and explored the
uh trends in in social connection over
the last 200 200 years in uh
in syracuse and poughkeepsie and so on
how do you get students to do this
um
well partly you pay them i mean it's a
it's a uh employment and uh and way that
they're working their way through school
and um
uh but
partly because they enjoyed working on a
project which was actually exciting
really is this is a really neat stuff we
had the feeling that we were
kind of exploring
a big problem
most of the time academics including me
work on
you know pretty small
problems narrowly defined so we can get
the get the facts quite straight in a
really narrow little area and i had all
my life done that kind of work uh and i
will in the pa in the future do that
kind of work but this was a big
expansive problem it was one that you
could
when kids went home over thanksgiving
they could tell their
their aunts and uncles what they're
working on and they'd recognize it as
their aunts and uncles would recognize
it as a serious problem so there was a
certain amount of excitement in being
involved in doing hard
careful research on a big topic
in the back you go into great
explanation of how you put this all
together but the thing that was
interesting and i wanted to ask you
about was the number of
well-known
endowments and institutes that
participated in this in one form or
another i guess
help underwrite it
yeah mostly the foundations that are
listed there in the back they were very
very helpful um were not actually
underwriting the research for this book
they were underwriting a set of other
activities that we've been doing at the
same time because at the same time that
we've been
uh carrying on this research
um
at the encouragement of many of these
foundations uh i've been working with a
group of leaders across the country that
is not just academics but
preachers and business business men and
women and and uh community organizers
and union people and so on we've been
meeting in a in a group called the
saguaro seminar to try to figure out
what are some
possible solutions to this problem and
that group has met um
roughly every three or four months over
the last three or four years
we've looked at issues like the
workplace what do we need to do in the
workplace or or religion how how can
religion help to re
invigorate american democracy or schools
what can this what role can schools play
in in trying to fix this problem what is
the status of religion um
religion is as a whole
religious participation is down as
everything else is in terms of social
connections down about
oh 25 percent over the last take going
to church for example is down by about
25 over the last 25 30 30 years but
obviously there are some parts of the
religious
spectrum that have had an enormous
growth during this period and there are
others that have had
substantial falls i mean the mainline
protestant churches for example and and
and attendance at mass among catholics
has dropped off a lot but that's
partially offset by the growth in
participation in
evangelical uh communities and what we
were talking about in the saguaro
seminar was well okay so suppose we were
to have a another one of these
what people call great awakenings which
we've had periodically in american
history in which people became began to
be more engaged and interested in
religion
how would that how could that contribute
to a broader sense of
of civic revitalization i want to name
some of these organizations
aspen institute rockefeller brothers
fund lilly endowment trilateral
commission pew charitable trust the
norman foundation
the catherine t macarthur foundation the
charles stewart mott foundation needs to
support the is it called is it's
pronounced saguaro yeah uh what's that
mean by the way
um
saguaro is a cactus uh out and out in
the west uh we use it as a metaphor for
social capital because the saguaro it's
one of these big cactuses with the big
arms you know
uh saguaro cactuses it turns out grow
invisibly almost underground for the
first 20 or 30 years
before they shoot up these big stalks
which then turn out to be hosts for many
different kinds of communities
uh for birds and insects and people so
we thought that was a kind of a metaphor
for social capital takes a long time to
develop and then it serves lots of
unexpected purposes carnegie
um the the uh
lila is that the wallace
digest foundation
why are all these groups and by the way
a lot of our viewers i don't know what
the number is some of our viewers when
they hear trilateral commission
immediately think conspiracy
[Laughter]
why would the trilateral commission be
involved well the trilateral commission
frankly was involved only because i'm a
member of the trilateral commission and
and uh and
part of this uh work on democracy was uh
uh what i was doing is
on looking at how these same problems
occur elsewhere
uh yeah i know that there's there's a
view out there i'm just frank it's a
quite silly view that the trilateral
commission somehow runs everything um
but it was it played a very minor role
frankly let me just ask you what is the
trial commission and why is it people
are afraid of it the toronto commission
is just a group of of uh businessmen and
and uh public officials and uh academics
from
it's called trilateral because it has
the comes from the three
advanced developing part developed parts
of the world
north america and europe and uh and
japan
um
it's been i mean i'm a member of it but
i'm by no means a spokesman for it or
anything and what's the goal and
well you should talk to them about it
brian actually i'm just uh i mean it
doesn't make do with a book frankly but
no but the reason i ask this is what
what are the goal of all these
what do they want to learn on this
what's what do you sense that when you
meet with all these people from these
different foundations what do they want
i think they want the same thing
ordinary americans a very diverse group
up there i mean as you as you may know
but from looking at the at the list as
you read it off there's some
conservative groups there and some
liberal groups and some
uh you know all sorts of different
groups are in that list and what is your
sense of why somebody begins to
underwrite something like this because
they they have in different ways each of
those organizations has an interest in
trying to
fix some social problem in america that
they think would be improved whether
that's
a
child care or or education or
economics that they think would be
improved correctly
if we could connect more and i think
they
you know there are lots of folks on that
list who don't agree with one another
but they do all share the view that
america would be
a better place to live in if we
connected a little bit uh more that we
would have lower infant mortality rates
some of the groups in that list for
example are interested in in uh teen
pregnancy and infant mortality and and
the way kids are that we did that and
some of the groups in there are
interested in an education and they
think
uh
test scores would be higher which they
would be if american parents were more
connected with their kids and some
groups in there are worried about
american competitiveness and they think
american economy would be stronger
and some groups in there are worried
about american health public the health
and the psychological health and they
think american
americans would be healthier if we
connect a little bit more so i think
people have a very just as ordinary
citizens ordinary folks have a very
different set of
interests in this in near the end of the
book um
chapter 24 toward an agenda for social
capitalists i want to read
your points and then have you expand on
them sure um
let us find ways to ensure that by 2010
the level of civic engagement
among americans then coming of age and
all parts of our society will match that
of our gra their grandparents when they
were that same age and at the same time
bridging social capital will
substantially uh will be substantially
greater than it was
in their grandparents era how do you do
that
gosh i think there's um
not any single uh solution as i say in
the in the
chapter that you're reading i think the
purpose of
my efforts in that last chapter to try
to provoke people to
suggestions that may come from others
but let me be more specific about my own
ideas i think with respect to schooling
we know some things that would work
we wanted to increase our the next
generation's interest in public
involvement in public affairs we know
things would work we know that smaller
is better we know school in small
schools people are have an opportunity
to take part in community activities and
they
and they develop civic habits we know
that we know that extracurricular
activities work we know that
band and football and
chorus and
debate and so on all those extra
curricular activities
give people skills that they carry with
them their whole lives and we know that
what predicts in adulthood who's going
to be involved as an adult in in
community life
uh is who's been you know played left
tackle or played trombone or or played
kingly or something so we know that that
works and we know it was therefore
really dumb
as american as many american school
districts did to cut
funding for extracurriculars
as a frill during the during the 1970s
and 80s and 90s because it was not a
civic frill
we know that
public service and
community community service works in the
sense that kids who get involved as
young people in school
in community service develop habits of
mind and values that stick with them so
we know some things would work in the
carry an area of schools that would make
it likely that another another
generation would be more involved and we
could reverse this decline second you
say let us find ways to ensure that by
2010 america's workplace will be
substantially more family friendly and
community congenial so that american
workers will be
enabled to replenish our stocks of
social capital both within and outside
the workplace
um
let me go back for just a second to give
a little historical context um
america between 1865
and 1900
underwent the industrial revolution
basically a third of americans moved
from fields to factories is where they
in terms of their place of employment
and then we spent some time adjusting
our labor law to the fact that we were
mostly working in factories now no
longer working in fields take child
labor for example when we mostly worked
in
fields
child labor met you know sarah picking
beans in the back 40 with mom and that
didn't seem like such a bad idea but
when we were mostly working in factories
after that transformation
uh
child labor met sarah working and you
know sewing shirts in a sweatshop but
that wasn't so good and so we had a
series of kind of clicks
in which we saw the world differently as
a result of
that change in the structure of the
workplace now fast forward
in our adult lifetime
over the course of the last generation
we have all been through a bigger change
in the character of work in america
as more than a third of the american
workforce has moved from the kitchen
to the office
and yet with respect to the consequences
of that transformation the movement of
women into the paid labor force
we're still with respect to the
consequences of that for the rest of our
lives we're still pre-click
in the sense that we haven't yet seen
that now that most adults are working
outside the home
and most of us don't have a housewife at
home to take care of you know kids and
so on and i'm not for a moment what i
want to return to that those days in
which my daughter as we talked about
before is
is a professional woman i'm very proud
of her so i don't want i don't want her
to stop a professional career but the
workplace
has not yet adjusted to the fact that
most of us have two adults working
outside the home so that means
with what we need over the course of the
next decade or so are some quite radical
changes
in the structure of the workplace to
enable us when we talk about this as if
it were your problem or my problem who's
going to pick up the kids
tonight but it's not it's how is it how
america how is america going to educate
its kids when most adults are working
outside the home
that's a collective problem we need to
have a collective discussion about it it
may or may not but probably will require
some government action just as it
required government action to outlaw
child labor so i think it means
radically increa radical increases in
for example the family medical evac
which allows you to take time off for
sick kids
well sick kids are an important
obligation but it's not the only family
obligation and you should the burden of
proof i think ought to be on the
employer
to say why you have to work from nine to
five
as opposed to
having much more of flexibility in your
work life to enable you to to fit your
family and community obligations uh in
into the rest of your life so that's i'm
giving some general outlines here of
some kinds of radical changes that i
think would enable americans to to be
more civically engaged your third point
uh let us act to ensure that by 2010
americans will spend less time traveling
and more time connecting with our
neighbors than we do today that we will
live in more integrated and pedestrian
friendly areas and that the design of
our communities and the availability of
public space will encourage more casual
socializing with friends and neighbors
yeah one of the things that i was
surprised to find when we did this
research is that uh in a measurable way
uh urban sprawl metropolitan sprawl has
contributed to civic disengagement i
mean the the general factors you know
from reading the book is that
every ten minutes more of additional
commuting time
cuts all forms of social connection by
ten percent ten minutes more commuting
time means ten percent fewer dinner
parties ten percent fewer dinners with
your own family ten percent fewer club
meetings ten percent less church going
and so on 20 minutes more means 20
percent less of all those things so
urban metropolitan sprawl
and the time we spend sitting in in
metal boxes
has had a negative effect on our
connections with our family and our
community and our
our friends and so on
and therefore i think that there there
are good social reasons not just
environmental reasons for the sorts of
anti-sprawl initiatives that people in
atlanta for example atlanta now has a
quite has engaged in in the state of
georgia has engaged in a quite
systematic uh set of public policy
initiatives designed to reduce
sprawl largely for
there i think for environmental reasons
but i think it's also true that our
family community life would be better if
we could avoid
that proliferation of long commutes
number four let us
spur a new pluralistic socially
responsible great awakening so that by
2010 americans will be more deeply
engaged than we are today in one or
another spiritual
community of meaning while at the same
time becoming more tolerant of the
faiths and practices of other americans
yeah
religion is an important part of
american social capital um brian about
half of as a rough rule of thumb about
half of all social capital in america is
religious half of all of our
philanthropy is religious half of all of
our
volunteering is religious in a religious
context half of all of our
social membership group memberships are
religious so it matters a lot
for the total stock of american social
capital
how engaged we are in religious
activities and
um
as a citizen i think it would be
valuable if we had another one of these
periods in which america which we've had
historically in which americans have
become
more aware of the
values of religious communities of
religious values of course there's a lot
of talk about this that in this year's
presidential election and by and large i
think that's a good thing not a bad
thing that we're talking about
we're we're aware of the role of
religion
and it's positive contribution to our
society
there's a qualification one has to add
to that which is that sometimes
involvement in religion is associated
with intolerance of other people
and i think any of us who
talk about
increasing and and
having respect for the role of religion
in american society at the same time
have to say
always
yes and we need to do this in a way that
is tolerant of other people's faiths and
other people's ideas
and um
i think that's possible i don't think
that's a contradiction in terms i think
we can have greater a greater role of
religion american life and still have
tolerance
five let us find ways to ensure that by
2010 americans will spend less leisure
time sitting passively alone in front of
glowing screens and more time in active
connection with our fellow citizens let
us foster new forms of electronic
entertainment and communication
that reinforce community engagement
rather than for stalling it how can you
do that um well you know
as i said before i think entertainment
television is really not so good for
civic health uh and frankly uh of all of
the areas in which i
you could tell i have a kind of an
activist reformists attitude of all the
areas this is the one that makes me the
most pessimistic because obviously we're
not gonna abolish tv and i don't
i'm not campaigning to have a national
turn off
turn off turn off televisions
but i do think that
the internet which is in some respects
evolving in some respects merging with
television i don't mean immediately now
but i mean the the internet industry and
the telecommunications industry and the
entertainment industry are to some
extent merging
does to some
some degree open opportunities for those
of us who are concerned about community
building
to be more creative
in thinking about how we can
have
electronic
communications contribute positively
not
detract from or subtract from real
face-to-face social connections
um i think there are ways in which
television itself can contribute to
community activity by shining spotlights
on on opportunities for people to get
involved but i also think that the
internet opens up the possibility it
doesn't guarantee that we'll make use of
it but it opens up the possibility of
not creating some fictitious
cyber you know virtual community out
there in space but
using those techniques to reinforce real
face-to-face connections in our
communities community bulletin boards
for example in which you or neighborhood
neighborhood networks a colleague my
colleague of mine university of michigan
paul reznick as a computer scientist and
he's working on how to use the internet
to strengthen face-to-face ties within
neighborhoods well that's the kind of
creative way in which i think
electronic television electronic
entertainment may
have a positive role to play got two
more points number six let us find ways
to ensure that by 2010 significantly
more americans will participate in not
merely consume or appreciate cultural
activities from group dancing to song
fest to community theater to rap
festivals
let us discover new ways to use the arts
as a vehicle for convening diverse
groups of fellow citizens why would you
throw rap festivals in there among
cultural events oh because i think it is
an example of a cultural event uh
it the the
um there's a great example that i cite
here right here in in uh in washington
of uh of uh people using
rap groups and poetry slams
to reach to
communities
in this case african-american young
people who would otherwise not be
reached by bicultural activities and
using them to build community to build
connections the reason that i think arts
and culture is important is not you know
out of reverence for shakespeare or
something but because
arts culture
participatory arts and culture and
sports too
provide
an unusually good
vehicle for
making connections that cross these
other barriers in our society it's
easier to make connections across lines
of race or class or
or gender or or generation
often
oftentimes
if one is doing that in the context of
singing or or making cultural
productions of various sorts i happen to
be a
uh i have a soft spot in my heart for uh
choral societies because i i in my youth
spend a lot of time singing and i think
you can you can make kinds of
connections that are important
in us in a in an artistic and cultural
context i don't mean just watching or
listening i mean doing
art that would be harder to make if you
were in a quote more kind of civic
context in which you were kind of doing
eating your civic broccoli i don't think
that's i think
connecting can be fun why did you pick
2010 by the way
well 10 years out from when the book was
published i think i was trying to have
be uh talk about uh goals aspirations
that couldn't happen overnight but on
the other hand i didn't want to talk
about something was going to happen you
know after my lifetime let me get the
last one in here let us find ways to
ensure that by 2010 many more americans
will participate in the public life of
our communities running for office
attending public meetings serving on
committees campaigning in elections and
even voting
yeah i think in the end i'd return to to
politics i am a political scientist i am
interested in how
americans can take part in uh in
politics and not just in voting i think
it is a
this long-term steady decline in
political participation uh is a very bad
sign for our
uh the health of our democracy and i
think um there's a direct relationship
between the fact that people are
dropping out of politics and dropping
out of connecting with one another that
is the decline of social capital and the
rise of
all this money in politics the reason if
you ask why do we have all this money in
politics is because
politicians no longer can get their
message to voters through social
connections through churches or organic
clubs or unions or whatever
as those organizations have become
weaker and therefore they're relying on
electronic mass media which costs money
and i think the role of
money in politics is really quite
dangerous to american society so i'd
like to see
a kind of revision reform of american
politics in which we gave social capital
that is connections
greater weight
and less weight was given to financial
capital did national politicians have
impact on bringing us to where we are in
the last 30 years and can they have
impact on the future of changing things
i don't think they i don't think that
politicians specifically
bear uh
much blame for the
uh general decline in connectedness it's
not it's not because of politicians that
we've stopped
going on picnics or having friends over
to the house
i do think that as they respond to
public demand for greater
opportunity for people to connect with
their family and communities
that yes public national politicians can
play a role i think that the
presidential candidates this year and
both parties
are
genuinely interested in trying to find
ways
to make it possible for people to
reconnect
this is very high on the private it's a
kitchen table issue
it's high in people's private agenda how
can i just find more time and
opportunity to connect with people that
i care about
and
and i think public policy changes could
contribute to that have you gotten less
or more attention when the book came out
than when the article came out
probably more
um i certainly have talked to a lot more
people doing a lot more lecturing
um
yeah probably more i think it's not
necessarily the side of me or the book i
think it's a sign of the countries this
problem is maturing in people's
consciousness i think more people now
than five years ago recognize that this
is something we've got to do something
about what's your next book
how to look at this problem seen from
abroad how we can how what lessons we
can learn from other countries about uh
connecting we don't have much time but
this all started with italy in a study
you did how long had that study going
that took 25 years so i'm a slow writer
what was the number one thing you found
there
that if you wanted to know where lo
where italy was governed best where
people connect where people were most
likely to enjoy the benefits of good
government
it was a number of choral societies and
football clubs
you have any idea who did this cover for
you
uh yeah it's a it's an artist uh in new
york city uh he's done a lot of other a
lot of other fine work
bowling alone is the name of the book
and our guest has been professor robert
putnam thank you very much for joining
us my pleasure brian
[Music]
my
[Music]
for a transcript of this book notes call
1-800-777-text
for a video copy call 1-877 on c-span
to learn more about book notes visit us
on the world wide web at booknotes.org
next week on booknotes our guest is
peter hitchens author of the abolition
of britain from winston churchill to
princess diana
book notes can be seen every sunday on
c-span at 8 pm eastern and 8 p.m pacific
time
[Music]
you